We've got huge updates, guys, in the the
Oreo versus Anisa Jomha drama that's
been sort of unfolding over the last 2
weeks or so, 2 weeks, 3 weeks. I also I
called that the Oreo war would sort of
step back from coverage a bit if Anisa
kept talking about them, and he has. We
can actually take a look at that
quickly. Let's go to his channel. So,
you see you see here, we just look
through a little bit. Let's go back
like, you know, 2 months or so. So, I'm
not I'm not seeing Anisa's face here
yet. I think she's in the background of
the iDubbz one.
Maybe Covert Ares is part of it. Then
so, like a month ago, Anisa, keep going.
Another Anisa, still a month ago.
Still a month ago, another Anisa. Two
more Anisa. Another Anisa.
Another Anisa. Oh, but what's this one?
Anisa Jomha called me out, iDubbz's
wife. And I don't see uh another Anisa
after that point. He covered an iDubbz
or two. But iDubbz doesn't talk about
Nick. So, you might think, if you watch
Nicholas DeOrio, and only Nicholas
DeOrio, you might think Anisa has
stopped talking about him, and there was
nothing more to to say. But no, we
actually covered another one after that
point. And he was covering stuff from
that same channel that same day. He
avoided the one where she spoke about
him, which was interesting. And now
there's even more Anisa talking about
Nicholas DeOrio, which is once again not
being mentioned, not being covered. Very
interesting. Very interesting stuff.
Now, he has said he's going to do a week
of iDubbz content or something. But
that's that's not good enough, really,
is it? That's not good. I don't think
that's good enough. I think Nick needs
to respond to the things Anisa's saying
about him. I think that's what Nick
needs to do. And honestly, you know, I I
heard that Orgy was going to respond to
some Sleepy video. I haven't really I
don't even remember what it was about,
really. But it hasn't hasn't streamed
yet. And I think if Orgy doesn't cover
the Anisa versus DeOrio stuff when he
comes back, then, guys, I I don't know
what to say other than a big sweep might
be on, okay, guys? I think the big sweep
might be on
if Orgy refuses to cover Anisa versus
DeOrio when he comes back to stream,
okay? If he doesn't cover it, the big
sweep might be on, okay? So,
>> [laughter]
>> let's take a look at what DeOrio is
avoiding. Let's see.
Hello, everybody. It is me with my ugly
ass tattoos and my ugly ass jewelry.
>> [laughter]
>> It's me. I can't believe
>> immediately out the gate, that's a
reference to
[__] Nick was saying about
So, uh basically, a huge part of this
video is just about DeOrio.
>> I streamed last night, and now I'm
streaming this morning. Uh I do have a
push-up bra on. However, this shirt
specifically, like, it refuses to show
cleavage. I tried. Didn't work. Oh my
god, double shift. I know, I feel like
I'm back at uh
>> DeOrio watching this straight up and
[__]
>> dedication to cleave. I You know, I have
to be
>> I I think we're going to skip her
talking about her tits, so that's not
really what what I'm here for.
Okay.
Where's the DeOrio bit around here?
>> Like, you know when you go to like a
butterfly house or like one of those
bird houses where there's just like a
bunch of plants everywhere and like you
can smell the wet, but like positive?
Close your drawer, queen. What's go
Yeah, you're right. What No, I have bare
feet. I don't want to make
>> [laughter]
>> I don't want to make people horny.
>> Okay.
Jesus Christ, DeOrio googling what is a
push-up bra and falling to his knees
crying. That's a real thing. I I didn't
realize how real of a thing that was. Uh
but it is real, which is it's a lot.
More than the piss fetish, but not as
Yeah, too late. Um
number one wiener boy. I just want to
take a moment, okay? I
boy, shut my drawer. No, no, he'll come
in. He's coming in. So, I
um number one wiener boy. I just want to
take a moment, okay? I'm in a really
good mood for many, many, many reasons.
There aren't very many Well, there's
enough. I'm in a good mood for many
reasons, but one of the reasons why I'm
deep
DeOrio watching this in a clenched jaw
rage, realizes he [laughter] has his
[__] in a death grip for 40 minutes.
Slaps his own hand away, dude.
Holy [__] man.
>> I'm in a really good [laughter] mood is
um I finally was released from my um
shackles, in a in a sense, where I love
my husband, but he cares a lot about
people's feelings, even uh ugly, stupid
people's feeling. Uh he has a lot of
pity for the um for the slop tubers. And
he didn't want me saying he didn't want
me bullying them, cuz he's he was like,
"No, the If you're mean to them, they
won't be able to handle that. Their
self-esteem probably sucks. They're
already like really struggling. We
should leave them alone. It's punching
down." And Ian finally was like, "Okay,
uh
you can stream, and I'm not going to
tell you what to do. You can do whatever
you want." And I was mean to Nicholas
DeOrio for like
>> Wait, wait. Wait. Ian said she can
stream,
and she can do whatever she wants. Wait,
but
I thought
that she was just totally controlling,
and that Ian was like abused. I thought
Ian was like abused, and she made all
the decisions at every point, and never
took any advice from him, didn't listen
to him, and hated him, and thought he
was he was weak, and nothing he ever
thought or said mattered, and she just
mentally broke him and destroyed him and
turned him into someone he wasn't. Wait,
I thought that I Wait, that's that's
what I thought happened. Now, all of a
sudden she's saying that
he let her do something Dude, this just
doesn't Something's not adding up here,
okay? Something's not adding up here.
Like 2 seconds. And he And the other day
I I saw a clip of him bitching and
crying about how we're irrelevant and we
need him for clips, and he's not
basically he's not going to cover us
anymore, all because I was like willing
>> So, dude, literally, she's picked up on
it and is just doing the victory lap.
How does DeOrio keep ignoring her? How
does DeOrio actually bring himself to
just like totally ignore this [__]
Because she's talked [__] about him
once. It's crazy. It's so shameless.
It's so [__] shameless.
It would be It's just so embarrassing
for you to farm these people
for like over a year,
and you just totally [__] out the
moment there's any heat. The moment
there's any heat, it's so crazy. It's
just so transparent. I can't believe I
really I really can't believe he did it
so brazenly.
It really is just totally embarrassing.
willing to say, "Bro, your wiggling
avatar can save you from people seeing
your fat moon face, but it's not going
to save you from people hearing your
[__] high-pitched, shitty voice." at
like you need him for clips, and he's
not basically he's not going to cover us
anymore, all because I was like willing
to say, "Bro, your wiggling avatar can
save you from people seeing your fat
moon face, but it's not going to save
you from people hearing your [__]
high-pitched, shitty voice." I win. Big
[__] Such a baby, dude. Therapy is
good.
>> So, just DeOrio's raped. She He's raped.
She's She's sitting on stream going, "I
win. I win." You raped. You lost. Like,
it's over. You You farmed this person
for like 2 years, 3 years, 4 years,
literally years. They speak about you
like twice. You [__] out, and then
they're on stream just doing a victory
lap, and you just take it. You just take
it. This is what winning every drama
looks like. Being always being on the
right side looks like, guys.
It really good for me. I just If you're
going to do the avatar because you're
insecure about the way that you look,
you should also take a critical eye at
your voice and the octave that it's in,
and maybe consider a voice changer as
well. But anyways, I I'm shocked because
now my chat is normal.
Like, it's everybody is just normal
people. We don't even really have to
moderate. And even if we did, like, they
come in and they're like they're take a
critical eye at your voice. I I just
>> So, and now she's saying she's buck
broken the DeOrio fans, too. She's
saying the DeOrio fans just come in,
and they're like normal now. They
They've like,
you know, they realized that their guy's
been humiliated, and they just they just
come in, and they chill.
So, how do you let this happen? How do
you let this happen? How do you
talk about you and your your audience
like this? But yeah. So, I'm in a good
mood because it [__] worked. They're
such [__] Freak max. I'm just 40. Uh
freak neutral. Don't yuck somebody's
yum, but there's a limit. Yeah. Yeah,
and you're allowed to have your limits.
Also, I like some of you. Like, some of
the freaks, you've come in here, and
you're normal enough and sweet. I just
some of you just get so weird. But it's
it's stopped. It's very strange. I I
never thought I would see the day where
I I think it's stopping. I don't know.
You just make fun of them for being fat
and ugly. Uh and you can only address
that so much, lol. There's nothing uh on
go back and forth. Yeah, because I
[__] win, cuz I'm neither of those
things. And I have great hip mobility,
which he also can't say. And I have a
deeper voice than him. More muscle mass,
I'm smarter and
>> [laughter]
>> quicker physically and mentally. I think
I'm more entertaining. He better hope I
don't go for his weight.
>> She actually She actually talks about
something. That's the thing, man.
Anisa is actually talking about
something. She's actually laying into
DeOrio. She's saying why he sucks.
DeOrio can't do that. I don't know
what's wrong with this guy. He's like
totally fried. He literally can't go in
on someone anymore. He can't do it. He
just The last time I saw him try and do
it was with Chud. It's not that he may
have flown some of his audience, but it
was like the most blatant projection,
where he's saying, "Oh, you're terrified
of your audience." and all this [__]
It's He literally he can't stick to a
topic. He can't actually talk about a
point. He can't go in on someone
anymore. He's just totally fried. And
she just She just lays into him. It's
crazy. How How do you clip this? And
there are people coping in the comments,
too. How do you clip this? And you know,
they I show this clip where he must
[__] hate these people. He's not just
sitting there like begrudgingly, you
know, shriveled away, Jack, exploiting
this [__]
Like Oh, she's
She's raping DiOro again. She's raping
DiOro.
Yeah, because I [__] win. Because I'm
neither of those things. And I have
great hip mobility, which he also can't
say. And I have a deeper voice than him.
More muscle mass, smarter, I'm quicker
physically and mentally. I think I'm
more entertaining. He better hope I
don't go for his wig and take his whole
job. But his viewer count's already
dropping because girl with a [__] ass
bun and and [__] big fat bacon face.
Sorry, I didn't think that. Harley's not
fat. He's athletic. But uh greasy bacon
face and girl with a [__] ass bun are
taking his uh viewership. So, I don't
even have to do anything. Do nothing
win. I mog him by just existing. Sucks
to suck.
Bacon and egg. You're a little bit
taller, more baller. That that's just
just mag dumping DiOro.
I just like
How does he ignore this, man? It's so
crazy. It's so [__] crazy.
Girl uh who looks good, you should call
her. That's true. That's all true. I
actually do think I am taller than
Nicholas DiOro as well. He thought I was
being fat phobic when I was calling him
a toad with arms, but I was more
referring to his ratio of leg to uh
torso to arm. Like I don't think he's
that tall. He looks like he's maybe He
might be wider than he is tall. Maybe
not now. I think he's on Ozempic, but
still ugly. I do think I am taller than
him, though.
It It's just like a straight
3 minutes. It's [__] crazy, bro.
I literally I watched this earlier. I
watched that. I was like, bro, how did I
[__] miss this video?
How has no one clipped this [__]
It's so crazy.
Good, you should call her. That's true.
That's all true. I actually do think I
am taller than Nicholas DiOro as well.
He thought I was when I was calling him
a toad with arms, but I was more
referring to his ratio of leg to uh
torso to arm. Like I tall. He looks like
he's maybe He might be wider than he is
tall. Maybe not now. I think he's on
Ozempic, but still ugly. I do think I am
taller than him, though. So, anyways,
that's why I'm in a good mood. Ozempic?
I mean, I don't know, maybe he's not on
Ozempic. He lost some weight. I always
just assume Ozempic. Anybody who's
connected to Ethan Klein, I just assume
it's Ozempic. They They got the hookup,
you know? Oh, grunge fit is slay today.
Thank you.
Uh do you have a favorite quick
childhood food? Oh my god, I do. Uh it's
been a while. Frozen waffles with peanut
butter. I loved Eggo waffles with syrup,
but I Man, I wish Ian wasn't a celiac
because toasting bread Thank you for the
$2. Thank you.
Oh. And then mixing Oh, yes. sugar,
cinnamon, and butter. It's so good. If
you lost weight after 2024, Ozempic? I
often What it is for me, I'm going to be
honest with you. My eggs are dwindling.
What it is for me when I assume it's
Ozempic, it's typically when somebody
loses a bunch of weight and has no
muscle mass or change in face.
Especially no muscle mass because a lot
of people use Ozempic as like a
suppressant, but they don't work out.
So, it becomes very obvious. Like if you
look at Ethan Klein's legs, like that is
so glaringly obviously like Ozempic in
my opinion. In my opinion. Ozempic in my
opinion.
>> I As a big girl enjoyer Is that really
controversial? I I There are actually
people, I think, who go out there and
say Ethan Klein is not using Ozempic.
But it's like that there is like no sign
that he does significant exercise or
anything.
Ozempic has devastated the community.
[laughter]
So, ClockToYou said he can't curl 20 I
actually do think he can't curl 20 lb. I
do. I do mean that one. Uh and I I kind
of wanted to see cuz there was that one
time that I baited him into measuring
himself. I I will say I think Ethan
Klein is taller than Nicholas DiOro. I
Nicholas DiOro gives 5'4 energy. Um I
think Ethan is a little taller than me.
Like I actually think Ethan's like maybe
5'7. I'm 5'6 and 1/2, though. I'll give
him 5'7. But I I did like that I got him
to to measure himself live on stream. Um
and so I was hoping that if I asked him
to curl weight, I wanted to see I wanted
to see if he would do it. He would fail.
I'm I'm like 90% sure, but us bears are
also really hurting from the GLP-1
craze. Oh my god, that's so sad. I spat
out my coffee when I heard your Ian
impression for the first time. I got so
many compliments on that like in the DMs
from people that I was not expecting. Um
yeah. He tried to rip a shirt after you
called him out.
>> [laughter]
>> I His His grip strength might be be
worse than his um curling ability. The
fact a couple days after you made that
comment, he couldn't even
>> [laughter]
>> rip up a shirt. Oh, no.
>> to pull up my malicious edit.
>> out and still struggles with weight, I
get wanting to try Ozempic or something
similar. If you I want to like be very
clear. There is absolutely nothing wrong
with using Ozempic if you're using it
properly in response. There are a ton of
people who do have legitimate uh
problems losing weight, and they are
working out, and they are eating
healthy, and they need GLP-1s to get
them over the hump, right? There are
absolutely like obesity is a very
complex issue. And I don't think anybody
should be shamed for needing GLP-1. I
shame people for abusing GLP-1s.
Bang. Thank you uh for the 60 bits. I
sent pics of all the fluff balls. Oh,
there's six. Oh my god. That's crazy. Um
I'll check them out. The um
it's the abusing the GLP-1s and not
respecting your body, right? It's It's
you're not respecting your body. When
you look at Ethan Klein's legs, that's
not
>> Did she just [__] talk about Ozempic
now? I don't give a [__] about the
Ozempic talk. in my opinion, very
pathetic. And yeah, I don't know. It's
just
To me, it also screams um this is going
to be like a maybe like a too
complicated for the room take, but
somebody who uses uh Ozempic in the way
that In my opinion. In my opinion. In my
opinion. The way that Ethan Klein seems
to be using Ozempic in my opinion is uh
it's it's fat phobic in nature because
it seems like the only thing he cares
about is how skinny he is rather than
any like health related benefits that
come with GLP-1s. So, that's my take on
it. And that's why I make fun of him for
it. I don't think people using GLP-1s in
general should be made fun
uh for it, but he deserves to. And not
because of solely the GLP-1 use. I'm
trying to like cover my bases cuz I know
it It's going to get clipped. It's
Somebody's going to be like, she She
said that he's using GLP-1s and all
people want Yeah, guys, that I think
it's almost over. There's
There's one last thing I want to say
from this video.
>> pieces of [__] I'm not. Yeah, his
wife's constant fat shaming doesn't
help. Yeah. And again, I will clarify,
there are many many many many many many
beautiful fat people, okay? Nicholas
DiOro is not one, and Ethan Klein while
using Ozempic is not one, either.
Okay.
I thought So, guys, this is what I want
you to see as well. So, they end every
video with this AI song, guys. They end
all these videos with this This is what
Nicholas DiOro and Keemstar fans are
seal clap seal clapping at, guys. I want
to just make you sit through this.
Okay, they actually seal clap at this.
They think this is like [__]
brilliant. Okay, I'm going to make you
sit through this.
I heard the whole world say, "Leave her,
Ian, leave her. Your marriage has turned
fake and gay, and it's time for you to
leave her."
"Leave her, Ian, leave her. Oh,
[singing] leave her, [music]
Ian, leave her. For you'll just get
cucked, and she'll monkey branch. So,
it's time [music and singing] for you to
leave her."
"I thought I heard the whole world say,
'Leave her, Ian, leave her. She's a
crazy [__] Just run away.' [music]
Yes, it's time for you [singing] to
leave her."
"Leave her, Ian, leave [singing]
her. Oh, leave her, Ian I I literally I
cannot express how over it is for you if
you enjoy [__] like this. It is sexual,
100%. Yeah, I know because It It may
seem as though this is a pro Anisa
channel on first glance because
all the clips you're seeing to be Anisa
being
funny, entertaining, and and owning the
people she hates.
But uh no, actually, it's a
uh a snark channel.